the Senate Banking Committee held a
hearing today on the ongoing
implementation of the 2010 dodd-frank
financial regulations law and its
provisions to improve financial
stability and mitigate systemic risk
justifying or government regulators who
oversee the implementation process
including FDIC chairman Martin Gruenberg
and Comptroller of currency Thomas curry
good morning I'll call this here in the
order today the committee continues its
oversight of the implementation of the
dodd-frank Wall Street Reform and
Consumer Protection Act the officials
before us today have been asked to
update the Committee on their agency's
efforts to improve financial stability
and mitigate systemic risk this includes
strengthening risk-based capital
liquidity liquidity and leverage rules
for nation's largest banks and has in
risk management facilitating their
orderly resolution of any fiddling
financial firm and finalizing the focal
role and other painting rules these are
important efforts to help realize the
goals of Wall Street Reform who recently
significant progress has been made in
the past two weeks the Fed FDIC and OCC
finalized the Basel three capital rules
and issued a proposal to reduce leverage
at the largest firms the F sock also
takes certain financial companies for
heightened supervision I also want to
commend the agencies for working to
strike the right balance and the role
writing process and for taking steps to
address concerns where I can remember
Crapo and I raised in a February letter
regarding the treatment of community
banks and insurance companies new rules
should focus on reducing risk that
applied one-size-fits-all approach to
first marketplace while progress has
been made it has been nearly five years
since reckless financial firms put our
economy in jeopardy and three years
since the passage of the Wall Street
Reform
it is time to finish implementing these
reforms as quickly as possible to put an
end to too big to fail and to protect
American taxpayers from ever again
beating out a financial feeling
financial company I've asked our
witnesses to outline when their agencies
will finalize the remaining rules were
acquired by that Congress must also do
its jobs by confirming well-qualified
nominees and providing funding to allow
regulators to write and enforce the
rules only them will we have a
regulatory system that is ready to
identify and respond the the greatest
risk to our nation's economic well-being
I now turn to break and member carpeau
for his opening statement
Thank You mr. chairman today we've asked
our regulators to address the
implementation of titles 1 and title 2
of the dodd-frank act title 1 of
dodd-frank brought us the financial
stability Oversight Council heightened
Prudential standards increased leverage
and risk-based capital requirements
while title 2 established a new system
for resolution of systemically important
non-bank financial companies the US
banking system and capital markets must
remain the preferred destination for
investors throughout the world it's
important that the implementation of
capital standards and orderly
liquidation are done properly without
overburdening our financial system and
without placing the United States
markets at a competitive disadvantage in
the past couple of weeks the federal
banking regulators have been very busy
issuing a number of rules and guidance
regarding capital standards very
recently the Federal Reserve the OCC and
the FDIC issued final rules
strengthening the regulatory capital
framework for banking organizations
including Basel 3 and as the chairman
indicated earlier this year he and I
sent a letter regarding potential
effects of Basel 3 proposals on
community banks and insurance entities
so I also appreciate the distinctions
made by the regulator's in the final
rules for these banks and insurers with
regard to the overall capital standards
and whether Dodd excuse me
and whether dodd-frank ended too big to
fail I look forward to hearing from the
regulators on these issues today I
appreciate the hard work that has gone
into these capital standards and into
producing and reviewing living wills but
many including myself believe that
dodd-frank did not yet end too big to
fail going forward we must learn more
about the additional steps that
regulators plan to undertake to
determine leverage and debt to equity
ratios for big banks as well as how to
treat short-term wholesale funding it
also remains to be seen whether and how
orderly liquidations are able to address
dissolution of systemically important
non-bank financial companies while
avoiding financial shocks to the market
as we approach dodd-frank third
anniversary there's a considerable
amount of work to be done such as
working through the complexity of the
Volcker Rule and issuing the outstanding
risk retention rules
encouragingly there does appear to be a
building bipartisan consensus that some
elements of dodd-frank may need to be
fixed at the last humphrey-hawkins
hearing
Chairman Bernanke identified the
end-user exemption the swap push-out and
community bank matters for relief in
which specific dodd-frank provisions
could be reconsidered at our recent
hearing on community banks it became
clear that both sides of the aisle
agreed that there is a need to provide
relief to community banks especially in
rural areas the regulatory framework
that emerged out of dodd-frank has made
it increasingly difficult for community
banks as they are disproportionately
affected by the increased regulation
because they're less able to absorb the
additional costs in the brevity of time
so that we can get to the panel quickly
I also wish to reiterate the points that
I've made at other hearings this year
about the potential for cumulative
regulatory burdens and the drain to our
financial system by the necessity of
well-prepared
analysis and how these rules will affect
our economy as a whole and may affect
our global competitiveness it's my hope
that today's hearing will also allow us
to address the critical and needed
dodd-frank reforms as a bipartisan
consensus grows that we can fix at least
some of these issues Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You senator Crapo this
morning opening statements will be
limited to the Chairman and Wrekin
member to allow more time for questions
from committee members I want to remind
my colleagues that the record will be
open for the next seven days for opening
statements and any other materials who
would like to submit now like to
introduce our witnesses Murray Merle R
is the undersecretary for domestic
violence of the US Department of the
Treasury dental as a member of the board
of governors of the Fed Reserve System
pardon Gruenberg as a chairman of the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
and Tom crate as a Comptroller of the
currency
I thank all of you again for being here
today I would like to ask the witnesses
to please keep your remarks to five
minutes your fault written statements
probably included in their hearing
record under secretary Miller you may
begin your testimony chairman Johnson
ranking member Crapo and members of the
committee thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify today I would
like to update the committee on several
important regulatory developments since
I appeared before you in February in
April the financial stability Oversight
Council released its 2013 annual report
and in May secretary Lu testified before
this committee on the report at the
beginning of June the council voted to
make proposed designations of an initial
set of non-bank financial companies
under Section 113 of the dodd-frank Act
earlier this week the council made final
designations of two companies in this
initial set that did not request
hearings American International Group
and General Electric Capital Corporation
one other company currently subject to a
proposed designation requested a hearing
which will be held no later than early
August with a final decision by the
council no later than the beginning of
October this is an ongoing process and
the council will continue to evaluate
other companies for potential
designation the bank regulatory agencies
have just finalized an important set of
rules codifying the Basel capital
requirements for banks and bank holding
companies they also proposed a leverage
requirement earlier this week as a
companion to the capital requirements I
will defer to my colleagues on the panel
to discuss the details of these rules
but the progress we have made on both a
significantly stronger capital regime
and the expansion of the Supervisory
umbrella to cover designated non-bank
financial companies our key developments
in strengthening our financial system in
February I also highlighted the
council's work on money market mutual
fund reform at the end of 2012 the
council issued proposed recommendations
on money fund reforms for public comment
throughout this process we have made it
clear that the SEC is the primary
regulator and should take the lead in
driving reforms in June the SEC proposed
regulations to reduce the risks
presented by money funds public comments
will provide important feedback and
information for the SEC to consider in
developing a final rule also in June
Treasury's Federal Insurance office
released its first annual report on the
insurance industry and is working to
complete its report on the modernization
and improvement of insurance regulation
in the United States I would also like
to highlight for the committee a few
areas where Treasury intends to direct
significant attention and resources
during the remainder of the year to
complete key outstanding pieces of
reform in his capacity as chairperson of
the council's secretary Lew is
responsible for coordinating the
regulations issued by the rulemaking
agencies responsible for implementing
the Volcker Rule and the risk retention
rule
finalizing these regulations will
continue to be a top priority for the
secretary and the Treasury Department
Treasury will also continue to engage
closely with our regulatory counterparts
at home and abroad to strengthen our
ability to wind down failing financial
companies while minimizing the negative
impact on the rest of the financial
system and the economy by the end of
this year we expect to approach the
point of substantial completion of
implementation of the dodd-frank act but
that does not mean that we will be able
to relax our guard constant evolution
and the financial system and the
activities of financial institutions
will require regulators to be flexible
and to stand ready to address new
threats to the financial system thank
you and I would be happy to answer any
questions thank you go turtle please
proceed Thank You mr. chairman senator
Crapo and the rest of members of the
committee but this committees oversight
hearing in February I expressed the hope
that 2013 would be the beginning of the
end of the major portion of rule makings
implementing dodd-frank and
strengthening capital rules progress
over the intervening five months is
baring out this hope the Basel three
capital package is now final as the
chairman has noted I'll say more on that
in a moment the seventh section 7/16
role is done we've made good progress on
the Volcker Rule and are on track to be
done by the end of the year late this
year we'll publish a proposed rule for
capital surcharges on firms of global
systemic importance the proposed rule on
the liquidity coverage ratio which is
one of the special Prudential standards
for larger banks will be out in the fall
and with one exception
we should have final versions of the
other special Prudential rules for firms
with over fifty billion dollars in
assets done this year the one exception
is the rule on counterparty credit risk
on which as I mentioned in February we
thought we needed to do a quantitative
impact study on capital the finalization
of the Basel 3 package marks the end of
major modifications to the capital rules
applicable to the vast majority of the
nation's banks the final capital rules
substantially simplified some of the
elements of the proposed
rule that had been of greatest concern
to smaller banks for the eight largest
banking organizations already identified
as of global systemic importance we
still have some work to do in building
out a capital regime of complementary
requirements that focus on different
vulnerabilities and together compensate
for the inevitable shortcomings of any
single capital measure the first element
of this regime the Basel three risk
weighted capital ratio is now complete
second as I already mentioned since the
Basel Committee has just completed its
methodological refinements for the
capital surcharge and the largest most
systemically important firms will be
getting out of proposed rule on this
subject later in the year the third
element are stress testing and capital
review requirements is in place these
requirements provide a forward-looking
projection of capital needs under
adverse and severely adverse scenarios
taking account of losses that would be
associated with each firm specific
portfolios fourth the three banking
agencies have just proposed to rule
establishing a higher leverage ratio
threshold that will be an effective
counterpart to the combination of risk
weighted requirements fifth we will be
addressing in advance
excuse-me issuing an advance notice of
proposed rulemaking on possible
approaches to addressing directly the
risks related to short-term wholesale
funding including a requirement that
large firms substantially dependent on
such funding hold additional capital
sixth in the next few months we will
issue a proposed rule on the combined
amount of equity and long-term debt
these firms should have in order to
facilitate orderly resolution in
appropriate circumstances this is really
a gone concern as opposed to a going
concern capital measure but it is an
important piece of an overall effort to
confine the systemic risks posed by
large banking organizations as to the
form of systemic risk most in need of
further attention and regulatory action
I will repeat what I said in February it
lies in the very large amounts of
short-term funding other than insured
deposits used by financial intern
meteors the various forms of this
funding though varying in the degree of
vulnerability they pose are all to a
greater or lesser extent susceptible to
destabilizing runs of the sort that set
off the worst phase of the financial
crisis the advanced notice of proposed
rulemaking to which I referred a few
moments ago will address the particular
vulnerability that exists when large
amounts of this funding are concentrated
in individual firms but I should also
emphasize that a financial system
heavily reliant on such funding could
create a good bit of systemic risk even
if no individual firms were thought too
big to fail as the rules applicable to
Prudential II regulated banking
organizations take effect the chances
increase that more such activity will
migrate outside the Prudential
Regulatory perimeter measures on money
market mutual funds and the tri-party
repo market would represent a good
beginning to address this vulnerability
but I believe we need to consider
carefully possible additional steps in
areas such as securities financing
transactions to address the potential
for runs in short term funding
regardless of whether the borrower is a
large regulated institution thank you
very much for your attention
thank you chairman Gruenberg please
proceed Thank You chairman Johnson
ranking member Crapo and members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today on the FDIC's actions to implement
the dodd-frank act particularly in
regard to mitigating systemic risk I'll
focus my comments on the recent capital
rulemakings by the banking agencies and
also on the FDIC's implementation or the
system of the systemic resolution
provisions of dodd-frank earlier this
week as governor Tarullo mentioned the
FDIC board acted on two important
regulatory capital rulemakings first the
FDIC issued an interim final rule that
significantly revises and strengthens
risk-based capital regulations through
implementation of Basel 3
the rule was strengthen the quality and
quantity of risk-based capital for all
banks including by placing greater
emphasis on tier 1 common equity capital
which is widely recognized as the most
loss-absorbing form of capital the rule
also makes significant changes to
address a number of community bank
concerns raised during the comment
period on the proposed rule that I
described in some detail in my written
testimony second the FDIC joined with
the Federal Reserve and the OCC in
issuing a notice of proposed rulemaking
which would strengthen the supplementary
leverage ratio requirements for the
eight largest most systemically
significant US bank holding companies
and their insured banks the NP R would
require these insured banks to satisfy a
6% supplementary leverage ratio
requirement to be considered well
capitalized for prompt corrective action
purposes bank holding companies covered
by the NP R would need to maintain
supplementary leverage ratios of a 3%
minimum plus a 2% buffer for a total 5%
requirement maintenance of a strong base
of capital at the largest most
systemically important institutions is
particularly important because capital
shortfalls at these institutions can
contribute to systemic distress and can
have material adverse economic effects
analysis by the banking agencies
suggests that a 3 percent minimum
supplementary leverage ratio which is
required under Basel 3 would not have
appreciably mitigated the growth in
leverage among these organizations in
the years preceding the recent crisis in
addition to these capital proposals the
FDIC has made significant progress in
developing a more effective resolution
framework for large systemically
important financial institutions or
cities as required by the dodd-frank act
title 1 of the Act requires a certain
large financial institutions prepare
resolution plans or living wills to
demonstrate how the company could be
resolved in a rapid and orderly manner
under the bankruptcy code 11 large
complex financial companies submitted
initial resolution plans in 2012 with
the remaining covered companies required
to file plans in 2013 following the
review of the initial 11 resolution
plans the agencies developed guidance
for these firms
to detail what information should be
included in their 2013 revised
resolution plans submissions these
revised resolution plans will be subject
to reviews for resolved ability under
the Bankruptcy Code the FDIC and the
Federal Reserve will be evaluating how
each plan addresses a set of benchmarks
outlined in the guidance which posed the
key impediments to an orderly resolution
while bankruptcy is the preferred option
for resolution under dodd-frank if
resolution under the Bankruptcy Code
would result in serious adverse effects
on financial stability in the United
States title 2 of dodd-frank sets out
the orderly liquidation authority to
serve as a last resort alternative to
implement the orderly liquidation
Authority the FDIC has developed a
strategic approach to resolving asipi
which is referred to as a single point
of entry than a single point of entry
resolution the FDIC would be appointed
as receiver of the top tier parent
holding company of the Financial Group
following the company's failure
shareholders would be wiped out
unsecured debt holders would have their
claims written down to reflect any
losses the shareholders cannot cover and
culpable senior management would be
replaced as a detail on my testimony we
believe the single point of entry
strategy holds the best promise of
achieving title to title to his goals of
holding shareholders creditors and
management of the failed firm
accountable for the company's losses and
maintaining financial stability at no
cost to taxpayers
mr. chairman that concludes my remarks
I'd be glad to respond to your question
thank you
comptroller curry please proceed
chairman Johnson ranking member Crapo
and members of the committee thank you
for the opportunity to discuss those
provisions in the dodd-frank Wall Street
Reform and Consumer Protection Act the
reduced systemic risk and improve
financial stability the global financial
crisis was unprecedented in its severity
and exposed a number of fundamental
weaknesses in the regulation and
structure of the financial system the
dodd-frank act sets new requirements for
capital liquidity and higher risk
activities and provides additional
regulatory tools that will mitigate
future problems in my written testimony
I provided a detailed update on what the
OCC has done to implement those
provisions along with other steps we
have taken to ensure that national banks
and federal thrifts operates safely even
in times of economic stress this morning
I'd like to focus on a handful of key
areas first I'm pleased to tell you that
the OCC has completed work on all of the
rule makings required under dodd-frank
that we have authority to implement on
our own this includes rules related to
lending limits stress testing credit
ratings and retail foreign exchange
transactions we are continuing to work
on an interagency basis on other
dodd-frank provisions including the
Volcker Rule most recently we join with
the other bank regulatory agencies and a
comprehensive overhaul of the capital
rules that apply to banks and thrifts
on Tuesday like my colleagues I signed
the new domestic capital rule which
takes important steps to improve the
quantity and quality of capital for all
banks and thrifts while setting higher
standards for large institutions this
rulemaking includes requirements laid
out in dodd-frank
I also issued a proposed rule with the
other agencies that would double the
leverage ratio to 6% for the largest and
most interconnected US banks the new
domestic capital rule raises capital
ratios expands the base of assets for
risk-based capital calculations and
emphasizes common
which has proven to be the form of
capital best able to absorb losses the
rule also mandates that all institutions
maintain a buffer of additional common
equity and restricts payment of
dividends and bonuses if that buffer
falls below two point five percent in
addition for large banks and thrifts we
established a counter-cyclical buffer
that could be activated during up swings
in the credit cycle to protect against
excessive lending and we'll consider in
a separate rulemaking a surcharge that
would apply to the largest most
systemically important institutions with
these additional requirements the
largest US banks could be required to
hold Tier one common equity equal to as
much as twelve percent of their risk
adjusted assets during up swings in the
credit cycle throughout this process one
of my top goals has been to minimize the
impact of these rules on community
institutions we found that the vast
majority of community banks already have
enough capital to meet the new
requirements we conducted extensive
outreach and pay close attention to
comments we received from community
banks and thrifts as a result we made a
number of revisions to the proposed rule
particularly in the areas of residential
mortgage exposures a OCI and trusts
preferred securities that I believe will
effectively address their most important
concerns while the financial crisis
revealed the need for additional
regulations it also highlighted the
importance of strong supervision and
close collaboration among the bank
supervisory agencies at the OCC we have
raised the bar on our expectations for
the institutions in our large Bank
program requiring higher standards for
audit governance and risk management we
have focused particularly on independent
directors we expect them to set
strategic direction for the bank and to
have the knowledge and the will to
provide a credible challenge to
management in addition we are working
with the large banks we oversee to
reduce the number and complexity of the
legal entities within their
organizations and to ensure that those
entities align properly with with
business lines at each Bend the bank
this process will take time but it will
ultimately improve transparency risk
management and governance and will make
it easier to deal with the resolution of
large institutions that do get into
trouble
finally I'm pleased to say that the
national banks and federal thrift
supervised by the OCC have made
significant progress in raising capital
and have been reducing the reliance on
volatile funding sources at the same
time as sea quality has improved across
the board the national banking system is
substantially stronger today than it was
before the crisis we believe these are
important achievements but we also
recognize that much remains to be done
as we continue the important work of
implementing the dodd-frank act I can
assure you that the OCC will work
closely with the other regulatory
agencies to ensure that the banks and
thrifts we supervise are safe and
resilient enough to stand up to future
economic disruptions thank you very much
and if you happy to answer any questions
thank you thank you all for your
testimony
we'll will now ask questions of our
witnesses well the clerk please put five
minutes on the clock for each member
miss Miller
what steps are being taken to finalize
rules that will do the most to mitigate
systemic risk what's the timetable to
complete key rules and it's a chair of s
sock what is a treasurer we're doing to
better coordinate these efforts with
regulators here and abroad thank you
very much for your questions first of
all I think you have heard this morning
about some of the most recent progress
to finalize rules that will put into
effect the objectives of dodd-frank and
the broader capital regimes
internationally when I was looking at
the testimony that my colleagues
prepared today I thought it was very
useful to look at the helpful lists they
provide of finalized rules of rules that
are in progress and what's left to be
done and I agree very much with the
sentiment that we are closer to the end
in the beginning here I think that the
work that's been done to strengthen
financial institutions to put in place
the important architecture of title
seven on the derivatives treatment in
markets I think the title to work and
title one work to help with winding down
systemically large institutions is
enormous ly useful I think the one of
the most damaging aspects of the
financial crisis was not having in place
clear rules of the road of the way these
things should work when you get into
difficulty so I applaud the regulators
for the work that that's been done I do
think that we have some quite important
rules to finish and I think that it is
possible that we will see some
significant progress this year governor
Tarullo
and comptroller curry
I appreciate the steps taken in the
final Basel three role regarding
insurance companies what next steps will
the Fed take to create capital rules
there to Berger suited for companies
that focus on the business of insurance
well mr. chairman you refer to the
provision that we included in the final
rule that actually defers our capital
rules for firms with more than 25
percent of their activities and
insurance underwriting the reason we did
that was that as as you and Senator
Crapo know and have pointed out there
are a number of products that insurance
underwriters develop and then market to
the public which are unlike bank
products the the prototypical example of
that I think would be the so-called
separate account now separate accounts
come in a lot of different varieties
they're not susceptible I think to a
single capital treatment and they're
certainly not susceptible to the kind of
risk weighting we would do for a bank
asset so as the three of us were trying
to complete the Basel three package it
didn't seem as though it was sensible to
try to rush answers to some of those
novel questions but it also didn't seem
sensible to hold up the basel package
so we've we've delayed in order the
final rules on insurance-related holding
companies in order to give ourselves the
opportunity to look more deeply into
some of those products now having said
that I think it's important to note that
we do operate under a constraint here it
that is to say that Collin's amendment
does require that generally applicable
capital requirements be applied to all
the holding companies that we supervise
and while we can and will take into
account the unique characteristics of
insurance products that are not by law
marketed by banks and and other banking
organizations we don't have the ability
to risk weight for example the same
security that's held by a bank or by an
insurance company differently and at
some level doesn't really make any sense
to do it differently the the asset has
the risk that it has the problem here
mr. chairman comes I think on the
liability side of the balance sheet bank
centered capital requirements are
developed with an eye to the business
model of banks and the challenge that
the FDIC would have in resolving a bank
or now a systemically important banking
organization that would be in deep
trouble the more or less rapid
liquidation of a lot of those claims and
the runs on a lot of the funding of that
institution lie behind the setting of
the capital ratio but the liability side
of a insurance company's balance sheet a
true insurance company that somebody
selling life insurance for example is
very different there's not a way to
accelerate the runs of those fund of
that funding people are going to
continue to pay their premiums and
presumably they're not going to die any
more quickly just because the insurance
company is in some sort of difficulty
but we are not we are not in the
position to take account of that
different business model in setting
requirements which under Collins of
say they have to be the generally
applicable capital requirements so with
that constraint I can assure that we're
working as much as we can on tailoring
risk weighting for unique insurance
products but we are a little bit
confined here Mr curry and mr.
Guttenberg how will each of you your
agencies monitor in a very wait the
impact of the new bezel through
procurements and community banks to
minimize unnecessary burden Mr curry
Thank You chairman we would primarily
rely on our supervisory process we're
required by statute and by sound
supervisory policy to examine each of
our national banks and federal thrifts
on an annual or a little bit less
frequent basis for well capitalized
institutions and well-managed
institutions that would be our primary
method of evaluating the impact we're
very sensitive to the impact of the
capital rules on those institutions that
we supervise and that's been part of our
rationale during the rulemaking process
itself to make our both our notices of
proposed rulemaking and our final
actions as clear as possible to those
institutions through webcasts through
the publications that we jointly issued
and with the pamphlets that my office
has has issued but we plan on working
with the institutions and there is a
year before the next year before the the
rules trigger for community banks and
thrifts mr. Kornberg impact of Basel 3
on community banks has been a matter of
particular attention for us at the FDIC
as you know we're the the lead federal
supervisor for the majority of community
bank
in the united states so it's been a
particular focus which was reflected in
the close attention we paid to the
comments that were received on the
rulemaking itself and the changes as you
pointed out that were made in the final
rule in response to those comments but
in addition we really want to work hard
as these rule the rules come out and the
banks have to prepare for implementation
to be sure they really understand well
what's contained in the final rule so
we've organized a series of outreach
efforts focused on community banks to to
explain and make is clear and
straightforward as possible what the
requirements are we are going to be
holding outreach sessions in each of our
six regional offices around the country
where we're going to invite community
bankers from the region to either attend
or call in we're actually creating a
video of the presentation that will be
posted on our website that any community
bank can look at if they're not able to
attend the session we're actually
creating two guides a shorter one and a
longer one that'll be can be utilized by
community banks to facilitate their
compliance with the rule rule makings in
effect a short hand guide to compliance
with the rules and we're also
designating experts in each of our
regional offices so any community bank
that may have a question as they go
through the rules and are uncertain as
to how the rules would apply to their
specific institution can call and get an
individual to walk them through it and
this will also be a matter of close
attention by our examiner's as they
examine each of the institutions as well
as controller Curry pointed out for
community banks there will be some lead
time here in terms of the beginning of
implementation it will be January of
2015 and we really want to use that
period to help the institutions prepare
for implementation and put them in a
position so they can do so in a
reasonable and
effective way senator Crapo Thank You
mr. chairman my first question is for
the Federal Reserve the FDIC in the OCC
on July 2nd the Federal Reserve
finalized Basel three capital rules and
previewed plans for even tougher capital
rules for big banks the final Basel
three rule issued by the Fed addressed
only a subset of the issues jointly
proposed by the Fed the FDIC and the LCC
and on July 9th
the FDIC announced that it will consider
Basel 3 as an interim final rule and
proposed a supplementary leverage ratio
of 5% for large bank holding companies
and 6% for the banks that are owned by
these holding companies a number of
issues remain outstanding including
particularly capital rules for insurers
and large banks my question is can you
provide an insight for us into what we
can expect from the regulators on these
issues and when so I think on the on the
proposed rule on the leverage ratio we
put it out for comment as you have to do
with all proposed rules will receive cut
and we've got a number of questions and
then we'll receive comments on it but in
in the normal course you get the
comments you see whether there are
things you want to change and then you
put the the role into final so until we
see the comments obviously we can't give
a timeframe but I think everybody's
intention was to get the rule out get
the comments and then try to move as
expeditiously as possible with
finalizing that rule with respect to
some of the other things senator that
that the Fed specifically mentioned that
that are not OCC and FDIC initiatives
the the additional capital for excuse me
gone concern capital the the long-term
debt requirement is something which
we've been working on for quite some
time in close consultation with the FDIC
and I anticipate we're going to get that
proposed rule out in the fall
there there's still some technical
issues being worked through but I think
we've got a sense of how we want to go
about making sure that the resolution of
a large systemically important firm
could proceed smoothly the area where we
we haven't moved as far down the road is
in that wholesale funding area which you
mentioned in your introductory statement
as did I as I say I think the major
vulnerability that remains is that
associated with large amounts of
runnable short term funding and what we
want to do is in an advanced notice of
proposed rulemaking get out some ideas
as to how we might address that
certainly with respect to the very large
institutions and that's where the
relationship between capital and
liquidity requirements comes in when you
know when we could expect that I will
get the ANPR out in the early fall I
think but but just to be clear an ANPR
basically is not like a rule text the
ANPR says here's the way we're thinking
and tries to elicit at a relatively
early stage of regulatory development
people's reactions to those approaches
thank you mr. Gruenberg I think for the
for the FDIC that they in the Capital
Area the big outstanding work will be
completing the of the rulemaking in
regard to the leverage ratio we really
viewed it as a an important complement
to the Basel 3 rulemaking you know Basel
3 strengthened the quality and quantity
of risk-based capital frankly the Basel
3 rule in regard to the leverage ratio
did not have a comparable strengthening
and in effect the proposed leverage
ratio rule is to create a balance to
strengthen the leverage ratio in a way
that's comparable to the strengthening
of risk-based capital we think that
combination actually makes for the most
balanced and strongest foundation of
capital particularly for our largest and
most systemically important financial
institution so we really view that as an
important part of
to completion on the entire Basel three
package and as governor Trillo indicated
Iowa we would hope to reach conclusion
on that I would think by the end of the
year thank you Mr curry great focus that
the OCC is on reviewing the comments we
expect received on the Supplemental
leverage ratio we issued the NPR with
several questions where we're trying to
determine what the the potential impact
of that proposal would be both pros and
cons and we like the OCC our view that's
the supplemental leverage ratio as
basically belts and suspenders to make
sure we have a properly calibrated
leverage ratio that works well with the
existing risk-based capital regime that
we have in place Thank You senator Brown
Thank You mr. chairman
governor twirl thank you thank you for
your comments and answer to chairman
Johnson's question on insurance in the
Collins amendment and the work you're
doing there I this is Mike Mike white I
have a question for governor to all
first I we clearly agree we need
stronger better capital standards we
would both like them to be higher than
they are I'm particularly concerned
though that banks can use risk weights
and internal models to game there are
capital rules the Financial Times
reported today the biggest banks plan to
use what they said optimization
strategies not more equity to meet the
new leverage ratios an executive and
large US bank on Wednesday said quote
we're going to be able to pull a lot of
levers analysts at goldman sachs noted
in research for clients that quote banks
have a lot of options to mitigate the
impact unquote what more should we be
doing should you be doing in terms of
using the trial using Basel 3 using the
Collins amendment using the proposed new
leverage ratios in Section 165 of
dodd-frank to address these potential
essential gaming the capital rules that
did appear to be eminent well senator
Brown let me let me begin by echo
a term that chairman Gruenberg used
which was not true use the term but you
have the concept of complementarity of
the relationship between different
capital measures you know if we think
back to how we started getting
risk-weighted capital in the first place
it was actually in the early 1980s up to
that point the regulator's basically
used some variant on a leverage ratio
and then what we saw with savings and
loans and famously with continental
Illinois was that the banks were gaming
the leverage ratio by taking the most
risk they could for a given amount of
leverage there was at that moment when
the regulator's began to say they needed
something else which looked at the
actual amount of risk that the bank was
taken so that US was born the concept of
risk weighting which saw its way into
the Basel 1 agreement now what we saw
more recently I think in basel ii was
kind of the height of this was the
opportunity for gaming or arbitrage Inge
once you have your risk weighted capital
requirements in place the model driven
approach to internal model driven
approach to risk weighting has the
potential for problems both because the
models are backward-looking and thus
they may be honestly put together but
they don't contemplate new problems in
the world which can create different
loss functions they also have the
potential obviously to be gamed because
they're sometimes extremely opaque and
difficult to monitor effectively now
it's important to note Basel 2 has never
governed the capital ratios of any US
bank we are we are still basically on a
variant on Basel 1 and with the Collins
amendment we will always have the
standardized risk weighted capital as
our base but as I saw in research before
coming to the Fed in some other
countries the introduction of the
internal models driven approach pushed
capital down pretty quickly so in terms
of what we've got to do we've got to
take account of the shortcomings of each
of these the potential for gaming
whether it's gaming of risk-based
capital or as you just noted in the the
FT story the potential for gaming
leverage ratio
and to make sure that we've got a good
risk weighted approach which I think
we've now got in the Basel 3 package a
leverage ratio which is a strong
complement and floor to that making sure
that you cannot gain risk waiting to get
too much leverage and third and from my
point of view this has been the real
innovation in banking regulation in the
last four or five years is the stress
testing that we're now doing for firms
over 50 billion because what we do with
stress testing is we basically say we're
going to get portfolio specific and risk
specific but we're going to do it we're
not going to rely on the internal models
of the banks to do it we're gonna have a
law set of loss functions that the Fed
creates and we're going to run their
portfolios through that and I think
those three things together provide a
quite solid base each of which
compensates for the potential
shortcomings of the other what more do
we have to do I'll come back to what I
said earlier I think what more we have
to do is pay more attention to again the
liability side of the balance sheet the
short-term wholesale funding which can
run and I think what I'm interested in
is pursuing the relationship between
capital and the liability side of the
balance sheet which has generally not
been done usually its capital in the
asset side of the balance sheet I think
we need to complement that so whether we
do it through increased capital
requirements based on the amounts of
wholesale funding or some of my
colleagues have suggested through an
increase in the systemic risk surcharge
one way or another I think we've got to
take account of business models and
funding models which create more risk in
which of the firm's and the system so so
I I guess I would add that as a
four-three thank you let me ask my other
question of MS Miller you gave a speech
in April miss Miller in which you said
now quote the evidence is mixed whether
market participants specifically lenders
to bank holding companies nonetheless
provide any funding advantage to the
biggest financial companies based on
some
belief that the government would bail
them out if necessary there was a lot of
coverage on that's that speech in that
statement I'm going to read you
something else and then ask you a
question a quote a perception continues
to persist in the markets that some
companies remain too big to fail posing
an ongoing threat to the financial
system it produces competitive
distortions because companies perceived
is too big to fail can often fund
themselves at a lower cost than other
companies this distortion is unfair to
smaller companies damaging to fair
competition and tends to artificially
encourage further consolidation and
concentration in the financial system
the second statement was made on Tuesday
by the three other panelists why are
they wrong in you're right thank you for
the good question I'm not certain that
it's a question of wrong and right I
think we're in an evolving period of
time where perceptions are changing and
where the laws has put in place a regime
where we can actually work to eliminate
any perception or expectation of
taxpayers bailing out large financial
institutions to come back to my
statements I think that with the passage
of time with the passage of the
dodd-frank act with the implementation
of a number of these rules the the data
and the marketplace is quite mixed now
looking at the funding costs for large
institutions and small institutions in
any relative advantage and my ask was
simply that we do some more work on this
question particularly asking some of the
academics who've looked at this because
their work is rather dated and predates
the passage of dodd-frank there'd be a
good time to step back and look at that
again to measure the impact of the steps
that have been taken senator Perdue
thank you very much mr. chairman thanks
to all the panelists for being here and
for all your work first I just want to
briefly and publicly again applaud the
FDIC decision on capital I think it's an
important first step in the right
direction if I could ask all of the
panelists and I'm sorry if you're
repeating yourselves it seems to me this
sort of requirement is important and
hopefully effective because it's
systemic it doesn't just depend on sort
of regulations and regulators but it
goes to the heart of the stability of an
institution without folks having to
catch things in real time that may be
spiraling in a negative direction to all
of you fundamentally agree with the
premise of higher capital ratios as
enunciated by the FDIC proposed rule the
OCC is a member of the FDIC board so in
that respect I voted for the FDIC
proposal but also this is an interagency
effort by the OCC and the Fed and at the
same time that I voted at the FDIC we
issued our own as a joint rule on notice
of proposed rulemaking on the same sub
supplemental leverage ratio and Senator
that the Fed Simon simultaneous with the
FDIC board meeting voted on the proposed
rule as well right underscore this
really was a joint collaborative effort
among the three agencies and I think it
was really common agreement on this
point and in regard to the strengthening
of the leverage ratio the importance of
strengthening the cushion of capital
particularly for the large systemically
important institutions that really pose
a risk to the financial system
significant disruption to the economy if
they get into difficulty the value of
having a stronger cushion of capital to
make will enable them to better
withstand a stressful environment reduce
the likelihood of their failure and the
potential impact on the deposit
insurance fund was really a threshold
concern for us and I think the I think
there was a general recognition that the
three percent minimum leverage
requirement that's in Basel three
actually that was an important step
because it's the first time there was an
international leverage ratio standard
established for all the participants in
the Basel Accord so establishing that in
the Accord was was meaningful and
important I think from our standpoint
the analysis suggests it really was not
a strong enough standard particularly
for our largest most systemic
institutions which is why we came
forward with the proposal to strengthen
the supplementary leverage ratio
requirement great thank you and I didn't
mean to suggest by the question that it
was somehow FDIC only I understand the
nature of all the discussions and
decisions and proposed rule so all of
you agree with the basic premise then
the question in essence becomes what's
the right level what's the right number
what's the right percentage and I
continue to be concerned while this is a
very important step I think in the right
direction that it's not a significant
enough number it strikes me in
particular that you look at smaller
banks community banks without any
regulatory requirement they're way above
this and seems to me that's interesting
and instructive for two reasons number
one because the only thing getting them
there are market demands and pressures
about sustainability and viability
there's not a direct regulatory
requirement that gets them that high
number two they're not systemic lis
significant like the mega banks we're
talking about are
doesn't it strike you in some sort of
basic way that for the megabanks to be
way lower than them is the reverse of
arguably what it should be it's centered
I'm I think probably there's a variance
in where banks are on leverage ratio as
opposed to risk weighting and of course
you can this is that this is what number
of us were saying earlier there's the
importance of the complementarity
between risk weighting and leverage each
each kind of compensates for the way in
which the other regulation can be
arbitrage I think I think what's most
important though is the area of
agreement which you've been identifying
which is there needs to be more capital
in the largest systemic ly important
institutions from my vantage point the
vulnerability that I see is on the
funding side the short term funding by
these by the largest institutions that
that you know one can differ on what you
one is the road into the higher capital
requirements I think I'd rather respond
most directly to the vulnerabilities
that I see but again I think on
certainly on this side of the table and
from what I've heard on on your side of
the day is as well there's a general
agreement that we do need to continue
the process of pushing up capital levels
they've already been doubled in our
largest institutions in just the last
few years less risk in a doubling of
capital and we need to continue that
work over the next several years as well
and any other response to my observation
and I realize there's a variance in
everything but in general it's certainly
true that community banks are still way
above what we're talking about I'm a
senator you raise an important point I
think as a general matter the largest
institutions have managed themselves to
a lower leverage ratio of than the
smaller institutions I think that was
part of the impetus frankly for our
proposal it's a judgment call on how
high and how
asked to push it up the level we
proposed is a substantial increase by
our estimates if it had been in effect
in the third quarter of last year for
these largest institutions that would
have required nearly an additional
ninety billion dollars of capital at the
bank level and it over sixty billion
dollars of additional capital at the
holding company level we think it
creates rough comparability with the
strengthening on the risk-based side in
Basel 3 in the NPR we asked what the
question for public comment should is
this the right level should it be higher
should it be lower well certainly in the
comment period take into account the the
input that we receive right mr. chairman
if I could wrap up in 30 seconds I take
all of your comments as encouraging in
suggesting that this is an ongoing
process this isn't the final word
necessarily or the end of the road and I
certainly want to encourage that and let
me quote the Financial Times from last
night as further encouragement of that
they say quote US banks believe they
will be able to meet the new regulatory
requirement on debt levels by shuffling
assets between their subsidiaries and
using other optimization strategies to
reduce the amount of leverage they
report and that no bank said it expected
to raise equity to fill an apparent
capital shortfall of more than 60
billion dollars across the industry
close quote
so I am out of time but I just make that
observation now I realize that shifting
of assets is not necessarily
insignificant or trivial but it's a
significant observation I think that
they're not raising any capital and I
cite that as further encouragement to
continue down this path
senator Warren Thank You mr. chairman
mr. chairman as we all know Wall
Street's high-risk betting nearly
destroyed the economy but since then
we've made real progress with dodd-frank
simplement ation but despite this
progress the four largest banks are now
30% larger
they were just five years ago and they
have continued to engage in dangerous
high-risk practices so later today mr.
chairman senators McCain Cantwell King
and I will introduce a 21st century
glass-steagall Act for half a century
after the Great Depression
glass-steagall kept this country safe by
separating the risky activities of
investment banks from the basic checking
and service and and savings accounts
that consumers rely on every day the
bank's lobbied for weaker regulations
and eventually the regulator's started
unraveling glass-steagall and finally in
1999 Congress repealed what was left of
it so now we propose a 21st century
glass-steagall so that we can return to
the basics and try to keep the gamblers
out of our banks now based on what the
regulator's did to glass-steagall
over the past 30 years I don't expect
anyone on this panel will jump up and
endorse the new glass-steagall bill even
so we're going to keep pushing for it
but I want to spend my time today
focusing on another part of this issue
and that is that a few weeks ago SEC
chair Mary Jo white announced that she's
going to require admission of guilt
and a wider variety of enforcement
actions now you remember that under its
old policy the SEC required an admission
of guilt only very rarely pretty much
only when the defendant had already
admitted guilt in some other context or
had admitted it criminally now the SEC
has said it will be tougher when large
numbers of investors have been harmed
intentionally or when the defendant
unlawfully obstructs the Commission's
investigative process now I think the
same principles that apply to the SEC
enforcement would also apply to other
regulators so my question is whether or
not you've considered moving in the same
direction as chair white on admission of
guilt policies governor Tarullo what
about the Fed well
senator Warren after the February
hearing where you raised a similar
question I went back and and asked
people at the Fed to people do the in
the compliance and enforcement generally
to to think this through and we've had
conversations subsequent to that and I
guess I guess our at least provisional
conclusions are the following first it's
it's important to note that with respect
to the the Justice Department in the SEC
for example are essentially not
exclusively in the case of the SEC but
they're essentially enforcement agencies
that is they take rules which have been
broken and they bring enforcement
actions they don't have extensive
on-site supervisory presences one to the
precedent value of an admission at the
SEC for example is of substantial
consequence potentially for shareholders
derivative suits and other litigation
that may be working off the same set of
facts for us with Prudential Regulation
we are basically trying to protect the
taxpayers what we're most interested in
is making sure that any violations of or
or unsafe and unsound practices our
remedied as quickly as possible well
we're not we're not creating taxpayer
derivatives but let me let me just ask
you to question on that though governor
Tarullo I would have thought you would
have described your job as trying to
prevent them from breaking the law at
all well sure and that when you catch
them breaking the law you want them to
stop breaking the law but you also want
to impose an appropriate penalty that
and that we do we do impose penalties
and that means that you often settle
with them rather than taking them to
trial well sure and how much you can
settle with them for that is how much
they will really pay as a result of
having broken the law depends in part on
how they evaluate your willingness to
push them to trial so the question I'm
asking about is really how much leverage
you have and what SEC chairman white
said is that she's gonna step it up
she's going to be tougher and she thinks
that's going to give her better leverage
or at least I think that's the
assumption she makes here and what I'm
asking is whether or not the Fed plans
to do the same you know when I was here
back in February and I asked the
question about when's the last time you
took a large financial institution to
trial the answer was not good and it
confirmed the worst fears of the
American public that the government is
quite willing to take ordinary
individuals to trial but when it comes
to big banks they're not so enthusiastic
about enforcing the law against them and
so that's the question I'm trying to ask
about I understand it's different when
you have supervisory responsibilities
but you have a responsibility to see to
it that this law is going to be enforced
Venice is taking people to trial that's
one of the tools in the toolbox well it
is it is a it is a tool but actually we
have I think a more in some ways a more
immediate and effective tool which is
the exercise of supervisory requirements
and getting people to change what
they've done now
I appreciate that you have another tool
that you sometimes use quietly and out
of public sight the question I'm asking
about though is whether or not you're
going to require something more public
following SEC chair White's change in
policy so that she's going to require
admission sethe guilt which at least get
us to a place where we're doing
something out in public and perhaps
leading toward trials on a more regular
basis well I think the third point I was
going to make actually was was the sort
of third conclusion of our discussions
internally were was that there may be
instances in which doing so would be
warranted for a variety of reasons I
guess the first two points I was making
were simply that given given the a bill
of the tools and the abilities we have
and the effort to maximize the benefits
to the public of the resources that we
do have generally speaking the know the
use of the Supervisory
mechanisms I think is probably most
effective now that doesn't go to the
question of what the fine should be and
I think that's a legitimate question
whether you're doing it through a
supervisory process or whether you're
doing it through a quasi-judicial and if
so does this mean you will be
considering reevaluating your policies
along the same lines that the SEC has
and I think we're just in we're in a
fundamentally different situation I
think than the SEC I think we are in a
different situation now I think you know
if you've seen with the more recent
finds that have been substantially
larger than historic precedent I think
you do see some effort to to ramp up the
kind of enforcement mechanism that's
being used but I hope I'll say on that
governor Tarullo since I see that we're
over time and I will be careful here mr.
chairman I will say there's been some
real question about the settlements that
you've made we talked about the mortgage
foreclosure settlement also at an
earlier hearing and that congressman
Cummings and I have asked for
documentation about what the banks did
wrong and more details about how it was
determined who was going to get what
kind of compensation from that that was
six months ago we still haven't had it I
just want to make the point that if you
had real confidence in your settlements
and that if people could see the details
of those settlements what the banks did
wrong and how we determined you
determine how much money would go to
individual people then the public could
evaluate for itself whether or not
you're really out there fighting on
their behalf and so far you have not
been willing I think they think that's
that set of issues a different set of
issues because when one's tie if one is
talking about that of transparency of
enforcement actions no matter what their
origins law enforcement regulatory
administrative supervisory I actually do
think that the bank regulators need to
think more about the when we put out the
public notice of the kinds of
supervisory actions that have been taken
and I think just as in a somewhat
different context we've moved a long way
with
tests and the publication of results on
the stress tests I think there's a
pretty good case to be made for thinking
about putting enforcement actions the
orders that we will use as you say
internally out on the public record as
well well which i think does serve some
of those purposes but in our context
yeah I I detect in that some change and
I appreciate it and I say Mr curry I'll
get you next time okay thank you sorry
mr. chairman senator heitkamp Thank You
mr. chairman and just not to belabor
senator Warren's point but the best
enforcement tool is a good deterrence
and we know from a lot of experience in
in the work that we've done in the past
whether it's in prosecution white-collar
crime is deterred by a little sunshine
and an occasional piece of litigation
that can in fact expose bad behaviors so
I just just want to add my my two cents
to that effort but I want to take this
in a different direction this question
is really for mr. Trillo and Mr curry
you know there's been a lot of
discussion recently on the standards of
foreign banks compared to the standards
for domestic banks can you speak to the
importance of insuring foreign banks
meet the same capital requirements for
their US operations that US banks do and
I pass it to you mr. Toretto
Thank You senator well as I know you're
aware we have a proposed regulation on
foreign banking organizations which
would require that the largest foreign
banking organizations in the United
States maintain Basel 3 minimum capital
levels and also have liquidity
requirements I mean the reasons for that
are I think pretty straightforward one
the nature of foreign banking in the
United States has changed substantially
over the last 15 years five of the ten
largest broker-dealers in this country
or foreign bank owned
- during the financial crisis foreign
banking organizations of all sorts drew
at the discount window if they were
commercial banks they took advantage of
the various liquidity facilities which
the Fed put in place if they were not
commercial banks and thus it became
pretty apparent that at some level we
the regulators and and the central bank
were having to play a role when they
were in a less than strong capital and
liquidity position three I think it's
it's notable that any large US banking
organization in the European Union
already has to be separately
incorporated and meet local capital and
liquidity requirements so in some sense
we're kind of catching up with what the
European Union has has already done so
for all those reasons senator I think
it's very important that we got that FBO
reg out we're taking comment on it now I
know there's been some pushback from
some institutions that don't want to
hold capital in the United States mm-hmm
but I just think it's not a sustainable
position for us or any large country
that hosts large excuse me any country
that hosts large foreign financial
institutions not to make sure that those
institutions are stable within within
its own country because ultimately it
affects our financial stability as well
Mr curry federal branches and federal
agencies though under the current setup
we would be looking to the parent for
the free capital support so we welcome
the feds proposal with its FBL proposal
in terms of enhancing the availability
of capital here domestically we also as
part of our supervisory process our
agreements in waters with respect to
those federal branches and otters would
have capital equivalent provisions to
make sure that US customers and US
operations would not be adversely
impacted in the
event of insolvency of the foreign
parent and I raised this issue because
as we talked about systemic risk and as
we talked about what in fact our
challenge is looking forward not paying
attention to this issue could in fact
damage and undo every good deed that
you've been trying to accomplish in all
of this regulation and so and we're
going to be watching this issue very
closely not only from a standpoint of
making sure that there isn't unfair
competition but also making sure that we
are closing the loop on on all of the
institutions that in fact present
systemic risk to our to our economy
Thank You mr. chairman
senator tester yeah Thank You mr.
chairman and thank you all for being
here today I've got a couple questions
for governor Trillo and one one from
Mary Miller so Tom you and Martin can
can breathe a sigh governor Trillo first
off congrats on you on your efforts and
moving forward with the capital and
liquidity and leverage standards I want
to visit with this morning on a separate
dodd-frank issue which is the treatment
of non-financial end-users and whether
they're subject to mandatory margins as
you know the congressional intent in
this area was explicit and that
non-financial end-users should be exempt
from the mandatory margin however the
legislative language in the statute is
less clear then I would have hoped the
CFTC and the SEC have issued proposed
rules that exempt non-financial
end-users from that mandatory margin and
transactions in which there are counter
parties but the Fed has taken a slightly
different approach at a hearing before
this committee nearly a year ago
Chairman Bernanke indicated the Federal
Reserve's reading of this statute is
such that it requires you to impose
mandatory margin on non-financial
end-users despite Congress's intent to
the contrary
Chairman Bernanke indicated that the Fed
would be very comfortable with efforts
to make the exemption which was clearly
the intent of Congress more explicit in
the statute so we have introduced
legislation senator Jones and I
co-sponsored by a number of folks on
this committee that would in a surgical
fashion ensure that the statute is clear
is a congressional tent on this manner
so just to be clear what eliminating
this mandatory margin requirement have
any impact on the feds ability to set
appropriate capital or Prudential
standards regarding institutions book of
derivative trades simply simply removing
that provision would not senator so long
as it didn't go further and
affirmatively say that we couldn't put
Prudential requirements in an
appropriate circumstance super what
other checks and balances exist to
enable the Fed to address safety and
soundness concerns that could arise from
swap transactions involving
non-financial end-users well you we have
to basically we obviously have a general
safety and soundness Authority and when
we see things that are being done and
unsafe or unsound fashion we can seek a
change in that that is actually the way
we tried to navigate the Scylla and
Charybdis of the legislative language
and the legislative intent is to is to
set up something which tries to track
that good risk management but you're
right our reading of the statute said we
simply couldn't simply exempt it but I
don't I don't think anybody certainly at
the Fed has believed that we needed
anything additional in the legislation
and if the intent of Congress was not to
affect the end-users the vast majority
of whom are are opposing no systemic
risk whatever then we have no problem
with with that change okay now setting
aside the tools at the Fez disposal
clarifying this exemption from mandatory
margin for non-financial end-users would
not impact the ability of individual
financial institutions to set margin
standards based on their credit
assessment of counterparties that are
non-financial end-users would you agree
with that statement as yeah senator I
think that your intent if I understand
it correctly is basically just to change
the current law so that there is no
instruction from Congress to the
regulator's saying you have to put some
sort of margin requirement and with
end-users with the non-financial Indian
right exactly
limited limited to that
it doesn't impinge impinge on the
ability of any entity to do its own risk
management would not impinge on our
ability to use our full panoply of
supervisory tools okay so the banks
still have the ability to set margin
requirements but there wouldn't be a
requirement to impose mandatory margin
requirements that wouldn't normally be
required to do okay could given all the
other mechanisms that the feds
disposable and setting capital
Prudential standards regarding these
transactions in a more targeted fashion
is there any reason why the Fed would
also need the statutory authority to
impose mandatory margin on non-financial
end-users no sir okay thank you very
much we need to get this done I mean I
think we need to deal with this issue
very very soon and we're going to see
five to six billion dollars sucked out
of the economy as the non-financial
end-users raise money to set aside to
meet what I think are unintended
consequences and I think this is an
efficient and a shame
particularly since he intended this
drafting I was the shield non-financial
end-users from the costs which would not
reduce a systemic risk so we're going to
keep working on that I have a question
for you Mary Miller there's a group of
us off this committee that's working on
GSE reform to move us move the housing
system forward while preserving the
30-year note what is your opinion on
dealing with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
would you agree that this is an
important task to take on to make sure
that not only Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
or secured but taxpayers are protected
the 30-year note exists and we have a
robust robust and we don't limit the
ability to have a robust housing
industry moving forward soon we
certainly welcome the development of
bipartisan housing finance reform
legislation so we will carefully follow
the progress on this and I think we've
been pretty clear that we want to wind
down the GSEs and
responsible manner at the same time that
we protect access to credit for
Americans who need home mortgage credit
and we think that the proposals that
we've seen some of the white papers that
are now circulating on the backs of
improvement in the housing market which
is clearly a precedent for moving
forward with housing finance reform are
very useful in supportive of many of the
principles that we've already
established I appreciate that and I
appreciate both your comments and
governor trillo's and thank you all for
being here today
Thank You mr. chairman thank you I
understand that Senator Crapo has some
questions that will be submitted for the
panel I want to thank today's witnesses
for their testimony and their continued
focus on a safe and stable financial
system this hearing is adjourned
see ya your family thank you
we're gonna update on yours yesterday
the one that I don't track more closely
thank you
good to see you again
yeah you're going to head straight to so
you know what she I don't you
to